you'd be amazed with the things that you
can draw or construct if you have a
straight edge and a compass and a
straight edge is literally just
something that has a straight edge that
allows you to draw straight lines like a
ruler and a compass is something that
allows you to draw circles centered
where you want them to be centered of
different radii and your typical compass
would be like a metal thing it has a pin
on one end and it's kind of shaped like
an angle and then you have a pencil at
the other end now i don't have real
physical rulers and pencils in front of
me but i have the virtual equivalent i
can say add a compass and now i can draw
a circle i can pick where i want to
center it and i can change the radius
and i can draw a straight line segment
so i can move it around and i can draw
this is equivalent to having a straight
edge and so using these tools i want to
construct a line going through p that is
tangent to the circle
now it might be tempting oh i could just
let me just try to draw a line maybe it
looks something like this
remember a tangent a tangent line will
touch the circle exactly one point and
that point since it's going through b
should be the point p
another way to think about a tangent
line is it's going to be perpendicular
to the radius between that point
and the center now what i just drew
actually looks pretty good but it's not
so precise i don't know if it's exactly
perpendicular to the radius i don't know
if it's touching at exactly one point
right over there so what we're going to
do is use our virtual compass and our
virtual straight edge to try to do a
more precise drawing
so let's
let's do that
so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to set up p
as the midpoint of a line where the
center of the circle is one other end of
the line and the way i can do that let
me add a compass here
and let me construct a circle
that has the same okay so i've set up my
compass to have the same radius as my
original circle but now let me move it
over
right over here so now it's centered at
p
well why is this
why is this useful
well now a diameter of this new circle
is going to be a segment that is
centered at p so i'm going to have a
segment where p is the midpoint and then
my rate my center of my original circle
is going to be one of the end points
so let's do that so i'm going to add a
straight edge so make that one of the
endpoints and i want to go to go through
p all the way to the other side of my
new circle
now what was the whole
what's the whole point of me
let me try to do it as well as i can
what's the whole point of me doing that
well now i've made p the midpoint of a
segment so if i can construct a
perpendicular bisector to of the segment
it will go through p because p is the
midpoint and then that thing is going to
be it's going to be exactly
perpendicular to the radius because the
radius the original actually the
original radius
let me let me be careful here the
original
the original radius is part of is part
of this segment so let's see how i can
do this
so what i could do is
i'm going to add i'm going to draw
another circle
i'm going to center this one at the
original
at the original circle and i'm going to
make it have a different radius maybe a
radius
something like that
and now let me get i'm going to
construct another circle of this larger
size but i'm going to center it at this
point right over here
and i think you'll see quickly what this
will accomplish
so i'm going to construct another circle
of that same
larger radius
of that same
larger radius
just like that and now i'm going to move
it over here
over here
so what's interesting about the
intersection of these two larger circles
well this point right over here is
equidistant to this this end of the
segment and to this end of the segment
because remember these two larger
circles have the same radius so if i'm
sitting on both of them then i am that
distance away from this point and i am
sitting that distance away from this
point so something that is equidistant
from the two endpoints of a segment
they're going to sit it's going to sit
on the perpendicular bisector so this
point is going to sit on the
perpendicular bisector and this point is
going to be sit on the perpendicular
bisector so now we can draw a
perpendicular bisector we can go from
this point right over here the
intersection of our two larger circles
this point that is equidistant from my
two centers of the large circle
to this point that is equidistant to the
two centers of the large circle and once
again it's equidistant to these two
centers of the large circle but those
points are also the end points of this
segment so these two points are on the
perpendicular bisector you just need two
points for a line so i've just
constructed a perpendicular bisector to
p and it's perpendicular once again to
the radius of our original the radius
from the center to p of our original
circle
now that is going to be a tangent line
because this right if you're if we go
only through p or we go through p and we
are exactly perpendicular to the radius
from p to the center then this line that
we've just constructed is actually
tangent
so anyway it might seem like a lot of
work to do all of this you know i could
have started just eyeballing it but when
we do it like this we can feel really
really really really really good that
we're being precise imagine if you were
trying to do this in a on a larger scale
or if you're trying to engineer some
very precise instrument you would want
to do it this way you're going to draw a
very precise drawing maybe an
architectural drawing this could be an
interesting way to to approach it and
you know in times past before folks had
things like computers and whatever else
this this was a thing people actually
did